in world war one the ottoman empire made
the decision to join the central powers
as you'll be aware this decision was not
exactly in the long-term interests of
the ottomans
at a glance though the ottoman siding
with their age-old rivals in vienna and
against nations who could quite easily
reach them seems like an odd decision
which raises the question why why did
the ottoman empire join their central
powers
well as of 1914 the ottoman empire was
not in a good place
it had just finished the 90-year process
of losing most of its balkan territories
and it was fairly keen not to lose any
more and the ottomans had poor relations
with most major european powers
however it did have decent relations
with france and britain and had a
growing good relationship with germany
and since the only great powers that
liked them were now at war there were
many in the ottoman government
that felt that they needed to pick a
side on the pro-german side was enver
pasha the minister for war who had
previously served as the military
attache to berlin and had seen the
german army in action
he was thus confident that germany would
quickly and easily win the next major
conflict and that it made sense for the
ottomans to get on board with them
for pasha an alliance with germany meant
growing trade military modernization and
importantly an ally to protect
themselves from russian designs on
constantinople
on the pro on taunt side was the
minister for the interior talat pasha
who wasn't exactly
psyched for war but thought the risks to
the empire were much slimmer a war
against the central powers would see
little risk of invasion and would allow
them to fight their age-old rivals in
austria-hungary
on the pro let's not get involved at all
side was sultan mehmed v
however his position was largely
ceremonial by this point and so everyone
ignored him
so as of august 1914 the ottomans were
still on the fence about which side to
choose
and there were several factors which
pushed them to choose the central powers
over the antand
the first was the british seizure of two
battleships they had been building on
behalf of the ottoman empire this act
didn't just upset the navy but also the
people since those ships had been
largely crowdfunded
the second reason was simple it was seen
as the only way that the empire could
survive
previously the ottomans were able to
count on the british and french to
protect the empire's territorial
integrity
however their leaders now believe that
the empire's end was the sure thing
and so for people like enverpasha if
germany the ottomans closest ally lost
the war
the ottoman empire would effectively
lose too the third was the problem of
russia
many ottoman strategists felt that if
russia was doing poorly and came close
to leaving the war there was little to
stop the british and french offering up
constantinople to keep russia involved
and when russia faced several setbacks
on the eastern front the military felt
that the time was now to strike russia
and reclaim some of the ottomans old
lands
these things combined led to the
ottomans favoring the central powers
which is why when two german cruisers
fled from british ships into ottoman
territory the ottomans chose to shelter
them
and in return the germans gifted them
the ships as a sweetener and thus the
ottoman government's mind had been made
up
so what about the austro-hungarians
given that they had only recently
annexed ottoman lands and supported its
enemies well the ottomans didn't
actually sign a defensive agreement with
the habsburg empire because they didn't
want to because they didn't like them
they would fight side by side but only
because their joint obligations to
germany
the only problem now was public support
since the people of the ottoman empire
didn't want war
so how did the government get around
this easy they provoked a war instead of
declaring one
those ships that the germans gave the
ottomans were then used to launch
attacks on russian coastal cities
this was done under the orders of ember
passion upon hearing of this the ottoman
ministers tried to remove him
before this could happen a british and
later a russian ultimatum had come
through demanding an apology some cash
and the removal of all german military
advisers
the first two demands were fine if not
great but the last one essentially meant
the abandonment of any military
modernization
as well as the ottomans giving up the
only friendly major power that they had
which for many in government was a step
too far
and so they said no the anton declared
war and the ottomans were after this all
in on the side of the central powers
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bisonette kelly moneymaker marvin
cassal mo aaron the white
james castaneda marcus arsenal jordan
longley gustav swan rasheed ali
jerry lamdin maggie patzkowski
coppertone winston cayward spencer
lightfoot robert wetzel spinning three
plates corso wolff matthew shipley
anthony beckett and charles the first